Новини дня «Heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Доброго вечора! Приємно, що ви з нами!
Про новини спорту зовсім скоро
розповість вам Руді Церне.
Тож теми випуску сьогодні такі:
Дипломатичний наступ - під час візиту до
Саудівської Аравії президент США заявив,
що Сполучені Штати хочуть
стати державою-протектором для регіону.
Смертельна небезпека в курортній місцевості -
все більше пожеж спалахує в Південній Європі,
а кінця спекотної погоди досі не видно.
Мюнхен говорить «Прощавай!»:
після восьми років гри в клубі
Роберт Левандовский залишає ФК «Баварія» (Мюнхен).
Він переходить до ФК «Барселона».
Іноді інтереси переважають на мораллю:
США потрібна нафта,
та союзники у боротьбі проти Росії та Китаю.
Після візиту до Ізраїлю президент США
продовжив дипломатичні переговори
в Саудівській Аравії,
попри різку критику на його політики.
Це найделікатніший момент цього візиту.
Кулак до кулака - так з Байденом привітався
наслідний принц Саудівської Аравії
Мухаммед ібн Салман, якого Байден раніше
звинувачував у скоєнні жахливого вчинку,
називаючи відповідальним за вбивство
журналіста Джамаля Хашоґджі.
Але традиційно США та Саудівська Аравія
завжди залишались близькими партнерами.
Відтак сьогодні на Раді співробітництва арабських держав
Перської затоки завершився тур Байдена країнами Сходу.
Брігітте Заар.
Він зустрічається з президентом Єгипту,
лідерами Об’єднаних Арабських Еміратів
та главами іншими держав.
Вони ввічливі один до одного, але не щирі.
Маючи справу з Саудівською
Аравією та наслідним принцом,
Байден має балансувати між двома вогнями.
Раніше він заявляв, що принц має
бути покараний за вбивство Хашоґджі.
Тепер Байден хоче збільшити співпрацю
з Саудівською Аравією та іншими вісьмома країнами,
які зібрались сьогодні в Джидді.
США хочуть розбудовувати позитивне
майбутнє на Близькому Сході.
Ми хочемо бути вашим партнером.
Ми не будемо відступати та створювати вакуум,
який потім заповнить Китай, Росія чи Іран.
Америка допомагатиме формувати лідерство
на основі принципів.
Байден має великі плани:
спільні інвестиції в чисту енергетику,
транснаціональний інфраструктурні проєкти,
розвиток цифрових технологій
та новий союз проти Ірану.
Стратегія – не зовсім зрозуміла.
США хочуть об’єднати країни проти Ірану,
і водночас ведуть з ним переговори у Відні
стосовно ядерної угоди.
Але перш за все Байдену потрібно
більше нафти з Саудівської Аравії,
щоб протистояти енергетичній кризі.
Насправді кронпринц готовий збільшити
потужності з видобутку нафти.
Тож крім палкої критики, Байден привіз до Вашингтону
принаймні одну приємну новину.
Ельмар Тевессен з Джидду
У чому полягала суть цього візиту?
Це були чіткі сигнали Ірану та Китаю
і водночас обурення.
США залишаються тією військовою силою,
що зберігає безпеку в регіоні.
Для США це так само важливо, як і для Ізраїлю,
оскільки ідеться про протидію Ірану.
Вони також хочуть захиститись від
іранських ракетних атак та
запобігти потраплянню ядерної зброї до рук Ірану.
Навіть методом військових ударів у якості
останнього аргументу.
Своїми анонсованими економічними проєктами
Джо Байден
певною мірою уповільнив зростання впливу Китаю.
Він також ясно дав зрозуміти автократам цього регіону,
що майбутнє належить країнам, які дозволяють
своїм громадянам критикувати своїх лідерів, оскільки
лише вільний обмін думками забезпечує прогрес.
Тепер він летить додому і виглядає задоволеним,
упевненими в тому, що країни Перської затоки
вирішать значно збільшити видобуток нафти.
Рішення буде прийнято протягом наступних тижнів,
проте твердих зобов’язань не прозвучало.
Це не вплине на обурливі реакції
щодо зустрічі Байдена з кронпринцем,
проте ми стали свідками того, що називають
реальною політикою з конкретними обіцянками.
Наживо з Джидди.
Дякую, Ельмаре Тевессен.
Тепер до війни:
на Сході України Росія перегрупувала свої війська.
Міністр оборони Шойгу нібито наказав
знову посилити бойові дії.
Тим часом невпинно продовжуються  ракетні обстріли.
Наразі Москва підтвердила факт обстрілу міста Дніпро.
Це сталося минулої ночі. Загинуло троє людей,
а ще п’ятнадцять дістали поранення.
Російська сторона стверджує, що ціллю атаки
було оборонне підприємство.
Однак, за даними Києва, ракети влучили в житловий район.
Зі Сходу України, за 75 км від Дніпра,
наш кореспондент Дара Гасанзаде.
Постійно обстрілюють явно цивільні цілі,
як ви це сприймаєте?
Це дійсно так - обстріли цивільних об’єктів
відбуваються по всій країні.
Вже не можна говорити, що це сталося випадково або
було побічним збитком.
Зараз ми рухаємось на Донбас
та зупинились у готелі по дорозі,
де відбувалося святкування весілля,
але його довелося двічі зупиняти
через сигнали повітряної тривоги.
Батько сімейства сказав,
що він відправив сім'ю в Карпати,
щоб там вони були в безпеці.
Дитяче свято там закінчували у сховищі.
Люди тут не забули,
що Путін заперечує право на існування українців.
Можна змусити інших перестати існувати,
навіть не завойовуючи країну.
Це жахлива думка.
Дякую, Дара Гасанзаде.
Також наслідок цієї війни - загроза нестачі газу.
Його вартість зросте в будь-якому випадку,
тому багато хто шукає альтернативи.
За рік кількість використання міні-сонячних панелей
для балкону
чи саду зросла більше ніж удвічі -
стверджує Федеральне мережеве агентство,
в коментарі виданню «Spiegel».
Звичайно, компанії теж намагаються
покращити своє становище,
поміж іншим часто використовуючи
шкідливе для екології вугілля.
Про це докладніше Олівер Дейкер.
Компанія «Felix Schoeller Group» в місті Оснабрюк
виготовляє папір.
Виробництво досить енергоємне.
Півтора року тому з екологічних міркувань компанія
зупинила стару вугільну котельню та перейшла на газ.
Зараз роботу котельні відновили,
і вугілля забезпечує 50 відсотків енергії на виробництві.
Ми бачимо ризик дефіциту газу, що чекає на нас.
Вугільна котельня в цьому випадку – наша альтернатива
до 21 липня, коли на наступному тижні
буде вирішуватись питання,
як продовжувати енергопостачання.
Не поодинокий приклад, коли через загрозу дефіциту газу
багато компаній вживають запобіжних заходів,
побоюючись економічних збитків.
Це означає, що деяким підприємствам не вистачає газу.
Відповідно, виробництво має бути призупинене,
обладнання виходить з ладу,
що вплине на інші сектори економіки
та матиме каскадний ефект.
Що спричинить зростання безробіття
та призведе до зовсім іншої економічної ситуації.
Повернення до вугілля задля збереження економіки.
Це буде боляче для захисників екології,
але можливо за певних умов.
Ми можемо використовувати ці
вугільні електростанції максимум наступні два роки.
Після чого необхідно швидке припинення їх використання,
щоб залишитись кліматично нейтральними.
Як довго працюватиме стара вугільна електростанція
«Felix Schoeller Group» в місті Оснабрюк?
Питання наявності газу та його ціни.
Екстремальні погодні умови
зараз відчуваються у Південній Європі.
Зберігається спека, суха погода і, як наслідок,
виникають лісові пожежі.
Особливо від них страждає Португалія.
Через пожежі там запроваджено надзвичайний стан.
Подібні проблеми в Іспанії, Франції та Греції.
В Італії, на популярному морському курорті Бібіоне,
туристи були змушені тікати в море від лісової пожежі.
Більше про це розповість Олівер Фламм.
Вогонь посеред раю.
Мальовничий пляж Бібіоне став
пасткою для багатьох відпочивальників.
Ситуація перетворилася на кошмар.
Полум'я поширилося так швидко,
що деякі люди змогли врятуватись тільки у воді.
Незабаром берегова охорона
переправила туристів у безпечне місце .
Іспанія теж вже декілька днів бореться зі спекою
та лісовими пожежами.
Багатьом жителям Малаги довелося
покинути свої будинки.
Їх єдина надія – пілоти пожежних гелікоптерів.
Мій будинок це все, що я маю.
Сподіваюся, він не згорить.
Остання пожежа пройшла дуже близько,
але, на щастя, пожежники швидко відреагували.
Прилетіло п'ять гелікоптерів та загасити вогонь.
Я дуже їм вдячний.
Гелікоптери використовують ледве не кожну водойму,
оскільки ситуація може загостритися в будь-який момент.
Хоча вітер, який роздмухує полум'я,
змінив напрямок,
я боюся, що вогонь може повернутися до мого будинку.
У деяких місцях пожежі перекинулися
на територію Португалії.
Втім, ці люди можуть
лише безсило спостерігати за пожежею з відстані.
Вся надія на пожежну авіацію.
Пілотам доводиться виконувати надзвичайно
небезпечні місії,
одна з яких коштувала пілоту життя.
Його одномоторний літак
розбився в гірській місцевості.
Для португальців 38-річний пілот став героєм
у боротьбі з вогнем.
Він вважається мексиканським
«наркобароном над наркобаронами»
Рафаель Каро Кінтеро -
один з десяти найбільш розшукуваних ФБР злочинців,
якого розшукували роками.
Нині 69-річного наркодилера затримали
морські піхотинці Мексики
і незабаром передадуть США.
За нього влада виділила нагороду
у розмірі 20 мільйонів доларів.
Кінтеро звинувачують у вбивстві
агента наркоконтролю США у 1985 році.
Наслідком антисемітського скандалу
на виставці «documenta»
стала відставка генеральної директорки
Забіне Шорман.
На відкритті художньої виставки місяць тому
був вивішений банер
з антисемітськими образами.
Роботу індонезійського митця було знято.
Ще до відкриття виставки лунали
звинувачення в антисемітизмі
щодо кураторів показу.
Здебільшого у відпустку йдуть ті, кому
вона конче необхідна,
але в аеропорту доведеться додатково понервувати:
як і раніше, необхідно закладати час довжелезні черги,
які можуть тривати годинами. Сьогодні - не виняток.
Не вистачає персоналу.
Тисячі рейсів скасовано.
І виходу із ситуації досі немає.
Репортаж Торге Боде.
Сім'я Єнер їде сьогодні у відпустку.
Їхнє місце призначення - Кіпр.
Проте не так сталося, як гадалося.
Сьогодні вранці в аеропорту Дюссельдорфа
утворилися п'ятигодинні черги.
Треба чекати. І це дратує,
особливо коли ти з маленькими дітьми.
Спочатку з нетерпінням чекаєш, а потім думаєш:
«Ого, як неорганізовано».
Причиною багатогодинних черг
досі залишається нестача персоналу,
передусім у відділі безпеки.
Лише на цих вихідних з Дюссельдорфа
мають вилетіти майже 200 тисяч людей.
Деякі це сприймають спокійно, але не всі.
Це просто катастрофа.
Зараз ще більш-менш,
але коли ми тільки прийшли,
за годину просунулись аж на 10 метрів.
Мушу зізнатися,
я ледь не заплакала.
На жаль, вони зекономили дуже дивним чином -
цього разу на персоналі.
Але я сприймаю це як погоду.
Що є, то є.
Ще більше занепокоєння виникло
у франкфуртському аеропорту
незадовго до початку сезону.
Через побоювання хаосу з наступного тижня
тут суттєво зменшать кількість рейсів на годину.
Відверто кажучи,
деякі рейси будуть скасовані.
Занепокоєння не оминуло також пілотів.
Хаос із залів очікування дістався до кабіни пілотів.
Оскільки затримки рейсів та години очікування
спричиняють стрес та понаднормовий робочий час.
Законом передбачено
запобіжні заходи для персоналу.
Виснажені екіпажі не мають права літати,
тобто для їхнього рейсу
потрібно залучити резервний екіпаж.
Проте резервний екіпаж або відсутній,
або також перевтомлений,
тому рейс не може вилетіти у запланований час.
Поки налагодиться ситуація з додатковим персоналом,
мине не один тиждень.
Тоді сезон відпусток вже мине.
Альтернативою може бути
відмова від польотів і відпочинок на батьківщині.
Наприклад, на пляжах узбережжя
Мекленбурга-Передньої Померанії.
Це популярне місце відпочинку,
але і його торкнулися світові зміни.
Багато гостей економлять гроші,
а деякі взагалі не приїздять.
Зі Штральзунда Анна Штадтфельд.
Ворота на острів Рюген у стилі цегляної готики:
у розпал сезону Штральзунд переповнений туристами.
Проте зараз навіть є багато вільних кімнат.
В одному лише готелі
«Scheelehof» - близько 20 відсотків.
За словами директора, інфляція та зростання цін
на енергоносії відлякують потенційних гостей.
Панує невпевненість,
наприкінці дня ми навіть не знаємо,
чи матимемо гроші у гаманці та
чи зможемо дозволити собі відпустку.
Пан Крегер отримує збитки не лише
на бронюванні номерів,
але також і в ресторані.
Часом відмовляються від аперитиву,
або замовлять дешевшу пляшку вина.
Всі економлять кожну копійку.
Майже всюди вздовж узбережжя Балтійського моря
в Мекленбурзі-Передній Померанії
готелі суттєво знизили ціни,
подекуди навіть вдвічі.
Особливо економлять гроші під час відпустки сім'ї.
Так, ми постійно звертаємо увагу на ціни,
що, де, скільки коштує, особливо їжа.
Ми подумали, що наступного року, певно,
ми не зможемо собі дозволити відпустку,
тож краще поїдемо кудись ще раз цього року.
Нині все ще користуються популярністю визначні місця,
як от океанаріум у Штральзунді.
Однак і тут може стати значно менше відвідувачів.
Звичайно, ми стурбовані, що наступного року,
коли люди отримають свої рахунки за електроенергію,
то, звичайно, їхні гроші підуть на оплату квитанцій.
Невеселі перспективи для індустрії туризму.
За допомогою знижок та спеціальних пропозицій
директор готелю пан Крегер сподівається
заповнити вільні кімнати.
Можливо, навіть, виробити стратегію на наступний рік.
А тепер до головної
футбольної особистості дня, Руді.
Роберт Левандовский залишає Баварію.
Так, він переходить з мюнхенського
ФК «Баварія» до ФК «Барселона».
Після важких переговорів
баварці та каталонці домовилися
про трансфер сумою 45 мільйонів євро
плюс 5 мільйонів можливих бонусних виплат.
Кілька обіймів на ранковому тренуванні.
Так скромно закінчуються вісім років
у мюнхенській «Баварії».
Вклад Роберта у ФК «Баварія»
заслуговує на повагу.
Він зробив свій внесок в успіхи клубу.
За минулий сезон 33-річний футболіст забив
рекордну кількість голів - 50.
Його має замінити Садіо Мане, до речі,
гравець «Ліверпуля».
До того ж Серж Гнабрі продовжить
свій контракт до 2026 року.
А жіноча збірна Німеччини
з футболу зустрінеться сьогодні в
останньому груповому матчі ЧЄ з Фінляндією.
Після двох перемог команда
виходить до чвертьфіналу з першого місця.
На зв'язку Катя Штрезо з Мілтон-Кінс.
З якими настановами тренерка збірної
випускає гравчинь на поле?
Ціль зрозуміла - потрібно виграти останній груповий
матч, бажано «в суху».
Мартіна Фосс-Текленбург,у порівнянні з попередніми
іграми, трохи змінила стартовий склад.
Дві гравчині мають жовті картки.
Ліна Магулл лікує стегно після травми.
Тренерка також сказала, що
сьогодні кожна матиме змогу вийти на поле.
Сара Доорзун зіграє з перших хвилин
на позиції центрального захисника. Початок гри о 21:00,
Фінляндія проти Німеччини,
ми чекатимемо на вас о 20:15
у спортивній студії ZDF live.
Дякую, Катю, до зустрічі.
Перший день Чемпіонату світу з легкої
атлетики в Юджіні, Орегоні.
Все у американській символіці - зірках та смужках.
Перший Чемпіонат світу в США.
Проте Еллісон Фелікс не отримає
свою 14 золоту медаль на Чемпіонаті світу.
Перший Чемпіонат світу
на території США очікувано патріотичний
і має бути багатим на медалі для господарів чемпіонату.
Проте на естафетному забігу 4×400 Еллісон Фелікс не
змогла завоювати свою 14 золоту медаль на ЧС
наприкінці своєї кар'єри.
Кеннеді Салмон, остання в
естафеті, поступилася спортсменці
з Домініканської
Республіки і посіла третє місце,
програвши також Нідерландам.
Подвійну перемогу в спортивній ходьбі на 20
кілометрів здобула Японія,
завдяки шведському бронзовому призеру.
Крістофер Лінке,
який був п'ятим на Олімпіаді, зійшов з дистанції.
А 100 метрів?
Американський спринтер Керлі показав
найкращий результат: 9,79 секунди.
Він побив рекорд найшвидшої людини у світі -
Усейна Болта.
Майкл Метьюз перемагає у 14-му етапі «Тур де Франс».
Австралієць випередив італійця Беттіоля
на дистанції 192,5 км.
Далі жовта майка - данець Йонас Вінгегор.
Сімон Гешке з Берліна
вшосте поспіль забезпечує
собі майку літера гірського заїзду,
як жоден німець до нього.
Це був спорт. - Дякую. Перш ніж спека візьме нас
у полон наступного тижня,
завтра ще буде не так спекотно:
на півночі - хмарно, на півдні - сонячно.
Більше розкаже Катя Горнеффер.
«heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом
очікуйте в перерві між таймами
близько 21:45.
Дякую за перегляд, гарних вихідних і
до завтра, бувайте.
Добрий вечір.
Апогей спеки очікуємо вже у вівторок
наступного тижня.
У західній частині Центальної Європи
температура сягне позначки 40°C- 41°C.
Було б добре, якби можна було
«законсервувати» низькі температури
цієї ночі.
У Верхньому Рейні очікується температура 14°C,
6°C у Фогтланді.
На півдні переважно ясно, на півночі - хмарно
протягом дня.
Отже, більш хмарна погода на Півночі Німеччини і
більш сонячна - на півдні.
Відповідно очікуються різні температури.
Західний вітер і хмари забезпечать прохолоду
на узбережжі Північного та Балтійського морів
за температури 19°C - 22°C.
На решті території від 22°C до 25°C.
У південно-західній частині температура сягне позначки
24°C-32°C, буде спекотно.
Вже в понеділок температура сягатиме
23°C - 36°C,
а у вівторок спека дійде до узбережжя.
Температура підніметься до 27°C.
А на Заході Німеччини температура сягатиме 40°C,
а подекуди 41°C.
У ніч на середу і четвер прийдуть грози
із заходу, а спека піде на схід.
Гарних вихідних.